Stephen Greenblatt what did you write
about Shakespeare that others haven't
I've tried to bring Shakespeare back
into the world in the world he lived in
and in our world I've tried to take the
traces that he left little chicken
scratching is really in the sand and
make a human being out of them what's
your reaction when you read about
professors and say he didn't even exist
I don't think too many professors say
this but there are people who have this
idea or that he didn't write these
people had to have a lot of strange
ideas about a lot of things Brian I mean
in the case of Shakespeare he left a lot
of Records he was famous in his own time
as a playwright and it would require a
conspiracy theory quite of an
extraordinary magnitude to cover his
tracks are you comfortable that he wrote
everything that juice you know that what
is it how many plays yeah 38 plays and
lots of poems did he write everything
absolutely everything by himself alone
no absolutely not he collaborated on a
bunch of the place he worked in the
medium in which collaboration was quite
widespread
like television writing or movie writing
but what's very striking is that the
work that's been done the last few years
very serious computer work and other
work trying to establish exactly the
parameters of how much he wrote and how
much collaborators wrote seems to
confirm to astonishingly more
conservatively than I would have
imagined the the the least interesting
place or the most problematical plays
the ones that aren't simply as good are
the ones that tend intended to
collaborate with someone else on
Pericles Prince of Tyre Titus Andronicus
the ones that are exceedingly creaky for
one reason or another Henry the eighth
they have interesting things in them but
aren't fully achieved those tend to be
the ones that were collaborative
performances the ones that he apparently
wrote by himself seem to be precisely
the ones we would hope he wrote by
himself when did he live was born in
1564 in stratford-upon-avon in the
Midlands in England and died in 1516 in
1616 right which made him what 52 yeah
what is it main stress
on a upon avon it's a town that was it
is located on the avon river so it's
upon the avon then there was a very
fancy bridge in Shakespeare's time the
same bridge is there now what is there
now of Shakespeare
well since the 18th century the town has
been a tourist site of a major kind so
there's a lot of Shakespeare there or at
least a lot of things claimed to be
Shakespeare sound actually quite a few
things that are actually from the time
that he lived the house that he lived in
that he was born in birthplace is there
the schoolroom that he was in the guild
hall where he might have seen his first
play is there are lots of things because
actually it became so valuable to the
town to keep anything associated with
Shakespeare that things are very well
preserved and Stratfor it's a lovely
place one of the reasons we wanted you
to come here was because over the years
of booknotes some fifteen and a half
years we checked in some fifty different
authors mentioned in our discussion
William Shakespeare I want to show you
just a couple so you can get the flavor
what they're saying about and ask you
about that great what I try to do with
you more and with serious columns is to
let the reader see politics almost like
a Shakespearean drama in the sense that
you have running characters if you want
to understand life there's no better way
than reading Shakespeare and then
discussing it with a lot of people one
of the characteristics of some
extraordinary people in particular
Mozart Shakespeare Keats are often used
as examples these individuals are called
to have negative capability what
negative capability means is that rather
than having a strong personality
themselves they had an incredible
ability to pick up the personalities of
individuals around them and to be able
to capture that in their works these
children have to learn English how are
they gonna learn English let's read
Shakespeare I'm a huge Shakespeare fan I
can recite for you the opening 45 lines
of which of the third from memory
Shakespeare was right about the Warriors
I'm a new world African who dreams in a
European language dreams in English and
that language is the language of
Shakespeare and Milton and Tony Mara
said the only figures of
had more things written about them than
Lincoln our our Jesus Shakespeare and
Napoleon when the alaa ghazzal mentioned
Lincoln it brings back memories of
reading about how he used to read
Shakespeare when he was very young did
you ever study that part of Lincoln I
didn't but it doesn't surprise me
because the fashioning of eloquence
first of all in the 19th century was
very much bound up with reading
Shakespeare and still really there's no
better way of crafting your mastery of
the language I think why is that
Shakespeare because he was the best
because he had the most astonishing
creative mastery of his medium of anyone
in our language and he was unrivaled in
his own time and unrivaled now what
makes him the best
he had astonishing natural gifts that is
to say there are things that are
difficult to explain other than they
must have been genetic accidents of
fantastic alertness to language and then
he found a way of deepening and
deepening and deepening his experience
and understanding until he could create
whole worlds he has the most at least in
the English language tradition the most
powerful ability imagination most
powerful ability to conjure up human
beings and complex convincing
circumstances of any writer in our
language what were his parents like
simple people at least in their social
background Shakespeare comes from a
modest social family one of the reasons
we don't know as much about him as we
would certainly like is that this is the
family that goes under the radar of the
usual 16th century 17th century
attention not because they weren't in
some way significance the father was the
equivalent of the mayor of Stratford and
not other Civic offices but because
they're not aristocratic people not
Gentry and the father was a Glover made
fancy gloves for the trade and also
probably a small-time user also bought
and sold wool illegally maybe some other
things to get by nearest mother came
from
farming family actually the mother's
parents were the yeoman farmers that the
father's father was a tenant farmer for
so the father married up by marrying
into her family but they're compared
with other writers from the period Sir
Philip Sidney or Sir Walter Raleigh
these are people of very modest means
modest background how many kids did his
parents have his parents had I should
now I forget the actual answer partly
because the pay the kids died in the
usual way rather quickly six I think but
of those only Shakespeare sister Joan a
brother Richard a brother Edmund
brother Gilbert survived for them it had
been eight actually if you if you did
the kind I'm sorry
and in what's the first document you can
find in his life that still lives
perfectly good documental which is a
christening record so we know we was
christened and the date the birth date
the April 23rd birthday is it just a
convention
because he was christened three days
later and that's the usual it's usually
a three day interval we don't have a
birth record but we have a christening
record and he was born into what
religion he was born in a very good
question he was born officially into
Protestantism England had decisively
become Protestant in 1559 after going
rocking back and forth but with the
accession of Queen Elizabeth so there
wasn't a tolerance of religious
tolerance in the 16th century with 17th
century for that matter and so England
was officially Protestant Shakespeare
nominally was born into a Protestant
family whether they actually were
Protestant thereby hangs a rather
complicated tale well you say that his
father John was a Catholic and maybe a
Protestant and we're not sure yes it's a
complicated world though probably not
more complicated than our um our life
world our spiritual world it's not so
clear if when when push comes to shove
that people are unequivocally one thing
and not another there are plenty of
people who are very very clear
their religious beliefs but they don't
want to walk under ladders and have all
kinds of other things that I if you push
very hard would look a little strange in
terms of an equivocal single thing in a
case I think Shakespeare's father you
know certain things that he did we know
that he signed off on the order to
destroy some of the old Catholic
whitewash over the old Catholic
paintings on the wall of the guild hall
as part of the iconoclasm part of the
destruction of religious art in the
period so he's definitely on board as it
were as a civic official in the new
Protestant World Order on the other hand
there are lots of strange signs that
seem to indicate that he has ties in the
other direction toward Catholicism so
often it's said that the at least
recently it's been said more
unequivocally that the father was a
secret Catholic and there are
interesting signs of this but as I say I
try to not simply hedge my own bets but
hedge the bets of that family by saying
that well maybe Shakespeare discovered
that his father was both Catholic and
Protestant as mother his mother comes
from a more unequivocally Catholic
family the father's will her father's
will is manifestly from it's formulas
Catholic will and his mother's family is
related to what are the leading Catholic
families in the area the Arden's of Park
Hall near Birmingham so that's a quite
important Catholic connection so the
likelihood with a mother that we don't
know is that the mother's roots are more
decidedly Catholic Queen Elizabeth the
first was a reigning queen for how long
she came to power in 1559 she died 16 3
a lot of years a lot of years and and
why was it that for instance the Pope
back in those days had really authorized
the assassination ever anybody get away
with it
well she wasn't popular among the the
Pope's of the time several of them were
in office during her reign for good
reason her father Henry the 8th was a
kind of equal opportunity persecutor
basically a doctrinally rather saunch
Catholic but
certain moment decided to seize the
wealth of the monasteries and tilted the
country in the least to that extent in a
in a Protestant direction but managed to
continue to persecute Protestants then
his son Edward was a child when he came
to the throne was really much more
doctrinally Protestant was in the in the
hands of tutors and Guardians who were
very in a much more determined
ideological way Protestant and they
persecuted the Catholics then when
Edward died Edwards sister Mary came to
the throne who sold his sister and Mary
Tudor was a very committed Catholic so
they started burning Protestants in the
country those who hadn't been able to
escape to the continent seeing what was
going to happen so the country had gone
back and forth Elizabeth had been
extremely circumspect she had a
fantastically dangerous childhood
because any indication she was in the
tower much of the time in the indication
that she was unequivocally Protestant
would have been greeted by lots of
suspicion and the possibility that she'd
be executed it was this happened and she
was you know a very young girl she was
unbelievably adroit at hedging her bets
and it hinting that she might be one
might be the other though it was
reasonably clear to people that she was
Protestant when she came to power
she made it much more unequivocally
clear that she was a Protestant but so
to that extent she was fair game
if in the political assassination
business because that was all that was
holding England clearly in the
Protestant camp it wasn't at all clear
to the Pope and to his spies that
England because there were many spies
for the papacy in England that that and
they spies were sending reports back to
the Vatican saying that the English
aristocracy was fundamentally in
sympathy with Catholicism but they were
keeping their counsel because of the
Protestant Queen so the Pope figured
that if he could get rid of the Queen
they could bring England back
via the Queen's cousin Mary Queen of
Scots who was a Catholic back into the
Catholic camp that made it very
dangerous when did you get interested in
all this oh I got interested in it
actually back in college and graduate
school in a case I became interested in
Sir Walter Raleigh and fascinated by
that life and fascinated by the whole
idea this was have a lot of years ago 40
years ago so about what ties the things
that people write in the lives they lead
particularly if those lives are striking
or interesting what ties these things
together why did Sir Walter Raleigh an
adventurer courtier remarkable fellow
why did he leave poetry behind and and
history what what accounts for the
integration of writing and life in this
period and that interest has continued
through to the present when'd you first
read Shakespeare first memory I have
reading Shakespeare is being assigned as
you like it and junior high school in
Haiti again well sweet my cuz be merry I
thought oh man I can't deal with this it
was it just seemed impossibly
old-fashioned and silly what do you say
to someone who says yeah I like the
story of Shakespeare but I really don't
like to read him well I usually would
say once you rent a video take a look
because the place was certainly written
they may have been written to be read or
they were read at the time things were
printed and people bought the books at
the time but principally they were
written to be performed so that is its I
can see that someone wouldn't want to
pick up a libretto Mozart libretto and
read it and but you wouldn't expect
someone to say I don't like Mozart what
I can't make any sense of this well you
need a little work to make sense of it
you have to know how to read music but
if you listen to Mozart didn't have that
much difficulty getting those mark
magnificent what do you prefer the plays
or the sonnets I don't know I'm not
someone who feels compelled to make a
choice but but I do prefer the plays
fundamentally to the Sun it's a I find
the sound it's remarkable fascinating
but I find them so richly worked so fine
and
complex such complicated mechanisms that
I rarely allow myself the time to play
with them enough to open them up whereas
the plays give themselves much more
easily to you where'd you grow up I grew
up in Newton Massachusetts and where did
you go to college I went to college at
Yale and then I was in England for a
couple of years afterwards
no Cambridge Cambridge and then I went
back to Yale for my graduate school and
where do you teach now I teach at
Harvard and what DT I teach English
literature a lot of Shakespeare to be
sure but from time to time I teach other
things as well partly in the field of
the Renaissance as a whole but I've
taught other things over the years
courses on memory courses on the
invention or the reimagining of
curiosity curiosities to be thought of
as a vice and then at a certain point
people began to think it was a good
thing and lots of other things
why has Shakespeare lasted so long and
and everybody you know you hear very
people say it's the most important
writer in the English language do you
agree with that I do agree with that I
think actually rather few people would
disagree with it
why has he lasted so long because he is
infinitely pleasurable and rich the it's
not that we can say lots of wonderful
things about him that are sound morally
uplifting but it starts with pleasure
and interest not in my view not with
meaning and truth it's not fundamentally
a like reading something that's making a
truth claim on you the Bible let's say
would be an example but it's about
giving you pleasure deep pleasure
complex rich pleasure and Shakespeare
was fantastically good at this and was
very clever in his own time and then
astonishingly turns out to be good for
centuries at doing an what looks like an
impossible thing of pleasing the most
sophisticated Raffin a complex demanding
literature's of his time and drawing in
hundreds thousands of ordinary people in
the theater the theatres depended on
bringing 1,500 2,000 people in an
afternoon you couldn't take 10 people
with fancy education sand please them
you had to get a huge crowd in there
paying a penny to stand up and watch the
play and you had to do both at the same
time and Shakespeare almost uniquely
figured out how to do that how much
education did he have more than people
think he didn't go to Oxford or to
Cambridge and thereby hangs a tale I
mean something happened in the family
couldn't might have been expected to go
to Oxford not that his father did or his
mother did they might have been
illiterate but they would have wanted
him to go if they had that possibility I
think because it was part of a strategy
of social advancement but he didn't go
on the other hand there's a exceedingly
high likelihood that he would have
continued all the way through or very
close to to the end of a quite rigorous
secondary school education which would
have come free to him and and we know
quite a bit about and was very very good
and that's true by the way not just of
Shakespeare but of that whole
environment in the Midlands and work
sure there are unusually good schools
and lots of remarkably good writers
these aren't people living in a remote
backwater in where they have no access
to education this is someone who had by
our standards least maybe not by the
highest Renaissance standards but by our
stand as a rather impressive education
at least in the what we call the
humanities Stratford is how far from
London a couple of hard day's ride in
its time and a horse on a horse yeah I
was along it was a long difficult trip I
mean was something you did
I mean Shakespeare must have done it
relatively regularly but not every
weekend how many miles is it I want to
say 80 or 90 miles but I I'm someone
will call in and correct me I'm sure
I've got it wrong by something or other
and at what age did he marry he married
at 18 which was probably not the best
idea you ever had in his life he married
a woman who's 26 years old and there's
he was a minor she wasn't
and we know that six months later she
gave birth to their first child so the
nervous Susanna Susanna and the
reasonable presumption is that therefore
they knew each other before he married
and what was she doing at the time you
know a farmer's daughter living in a
town called Chaudhary her father was
dead which gave her an unusual liberty
freedom she didn't have brothers either
who watching over her so she was an
unusually independent woman with a small
income and and obviously a will of her
own and what was he doing when he got
married well we don't know exactly it's
part of that time of his life about
which the records are silent there's
lots of speculation including the ones I
indulge in what we know is that he was
walking wasn't very far mile and a half
or two miles whatever it was from
Stratford where his family lived up to
Chartres eat a little town of Chartres
and visiting and Hathaway I think he
might have got a shot at Chartres II
because there's a very complicated
Catholic set of traces that lead back to
this very small town and that can be
connected I think though we have to
connect the dots to Shakespeare so he
might have gone originally for something
an errand for somebody but in the case
II merit he met and eventually married
and Hathaway this we're going to jump to
the very end and his will as you say had
nothing in it for Anne Hathaway first
draft of the will doesn't mention her
not to my loving and not to an nothing
to my wife of 34 years zero it doesn't
mean that she wouldn't have inherited
something anyway
they were what they called our rights in
the age and the people who want to
sentimentalize this will say well there
was no reason for the shakespeare the
lawyer to write anything in because
everyone understood that you'd have
these dower rights as his surviving wife
but it's very peculiar I've looked at a
lot of these wills now in the period and
most people make some gesture or other
to their wife often very touching
justice
of affection and love and there's
nothing what there is is a very strange
int'l in EI ssin that is to say after
the world was written the lawyer came
back and he wrote something in between
the lines on Shakespeare's behalf and
between the lines is written that he
gives to his wife his second best bed if
that isn't an insult I don't know quite
what is how many years did he live in
London and did his family live in
Stratford almost the whole of their
marriage the first presumably the first
two years between eighteen and twenty he
was around at least him we know he was
around long enough to have two more kids
of twins born before Shakespeare's 21st
birthday and then I think quite shortly
thereafter he must have gone we don't
know the exact time but he must have
gone up to London and then he stayed
there as far as we can tell right
through his virtually his entire career
until in probably in his late forties he
returned again the date isn't exact he
returned to Stratford to the wife to the
two surviving children back in Stratford
but it was basically his whole
professional life and in effect his
whole married life he spent apart from
his wife you say that his son Hamlet
died when he was 11 one of the twins
what was the death caused by we don't
know they didn't keep death records that
specified this we just have a death
record that says the son died at the age
of eleven 1596 could have been any
number of illnesses the actuarial
chances of making it through were fairly
modest though it's interesting that the
twin sister
Hamlet's twin sister Judith lived a good
long life by the by the standards of the
age so something I mean look in your
life or my life probably if we actually
look to think back there's something
that would have been likely to have
taken us off if they hadn't invented
penicillin or they hadn't done this of
that or we could have got strep throat
recovered from it also but who knows so
could have been anything
that took him away and what impacted the
death have on Shakespeare well some
people say no impact some people say it
was a cold bastard who just went on with
his work because we know that in the
years after the writing of after the
death of Hamlet Shakespeare his father
went on to write place like much ado
about nothing or Merry Wives of Windsor
as you like it that's to say
light-hearted happy place with lots of
laughter joy happy marriages but I don't
believe it I don't believe it not for
sentimental reasons really but because
first of all in addition to writing
those plays he also wrote King John for
example which has excruciatingly
beautiful and painful lines about the
death of a son the death of a child and
he also in 1601
so five years afterwards he wrote a play
that basically bore the same name as his
dead son Hamlet and Hamlet are basically
the interchangeable names in this period
we used interchangeably in the time and
I think there are many many fingerprints
of the dead son and if Shakespeare is
grappling with the death of his son in
the writing of Hamlet what was Hamlet
about the play Hamlet the play that that
Shakespeare had inherited the
Shakespeare Canada use what was given to
him but he could find in his voracious
reading but he could pick up and steal
from somebody else so the play that that
he inherited was a revenge story about a
son taking vengeance for the murder of
his father but Shakespeare Frey did that
story with extraordinary weight
extraordinary material about mourning
and grief and loss and what your
relationship is with dead people whether
they can speak to you any longer whether
they live in some other place or simply
have been erased forever and that weight
that extraordinary weight I think can be
traced back to the experience of this
loss of the 38 plays which one in your
opinion is the most important if there
is such a well I think Hamlet
actually an watershed play and I mean
it's hard to decide among with a
playwright who had so many astonishing
achievements whose careers so full of
recreating himself but I think that
Hamlet does represent the historic lling
pivot in Shakespeare's life I think if
he had died before he wrote Hamlet we
would think exceedingly highly of him I
mean this is a man who had written
Midsummer Night's Dream and and Romeo
and Juliet another magnificent works but
I think we wouldn't have guessed that he
had in him what then came out after the
writing of Hamlet let's say I don't
think we could have predicted that what
lay on the other side of Hamlet Hamlet
didn't exist was going to be Macbeth
Othello Antony Cleopatra The Tempest
this King Lear this astonishing
outpouring of genius tragic genius
especially a tragic comic genius and I
think that Hamlet is the pivot point and
there are other signs of it being the
pivot point there are there's a kind of
volcanic eruption of of language in
Hamlet though he had already written
about 20 or so plays there are suddenly
six hundred words not only that he had
never used before but that had never
been used before in any printed text
that survives in the English language
that that is an astonishing something
just erupting from him and then he
invent the language he did largely
invent the language I mean he he
invented it usually he's very cunning at
telling you what the words actually mean
when when Lady Macbeth says that the
blood in her hands that she's imagining
in their hands is gonna make the
multitudinous seas incarnadine
incarnadine the next line is making the
green one red that is say incarnadine
means making something red but
Shakespeare if he's introducing a very
fancy 50-cent word will usually give you
a five cent explanation afterwards so
that you're not completely lost in the
place but lots of the word he does this
I couldn't off him off the top of my
head recite to you the number of the
words that he uses but many of them are
words that we use in the English
language now like unpolluted let's say
in the
for the first time in Hamlet people
might have known polluted but they
wouldn't have used unpolluted and so
forth and so on he often plays with
language that way and then there's
something else that's going on in Hamlet
that fascinates me which I think
Shakespeare does here as far as I can
tell for the first time he had been very
good at giving motivations to his
characters if you think back at Richard
the third for example quite energetic
and wonderful tragedy he had a poor
history tragedy they'd written let's say
a decade roughly before he wrote Hamlet
he gives you a character who tells you
so much about why he's acting this way
I'm acting this way I'm this miserable
villain because I have a hunchback my
mother didn't love me I can't get any
women dogs barked at me in the street it
gives you 58 different reasons why he's
the miserable wretch that he is
murderous fellow that he is so you get a
very elaborate structure of motivation
when you get to Hamlet Shakespeare had
to play that had a very good
motivational structure for what is going
on the play that Shakespeare inherited
from the ancient from the older medieval
Danish source and then again from the
Renaissance adaptation by the by a
Frenchman named Belle for a that source
said look the King's brother killed him
openly the King's brother was not named
Claudius in the original thing but thing
so Fenn kills [ __ ] until the equivalent
of old Hamlet openly and it's a
Scandinavian world in which you're
expected to avenge a murder like that so
naturally if the old king had a son
which he did named Hamlet Hamlet would
be expected when he grows up to take
revenge against the uncle and therefore
stands to reason that the uncle is no
fool would want to kill Hamlet as well
as killing the father because he wants
to protect his life so in the original
story Hamlet has a problem he's a little
he's basically a little kid minor and he
has to live long and have to be able to
exact revenge for his father against
this miserable murderous uncle and
everyone knows this is what this is
about
so what little Hamlet does is start
drooling and acting strangely and
behaving like a lunatic
and people laugh at him and the rather
coarse way people laugh at at least in
those days people felt comfortable
laughing at idiots and the result is
that they let him live because he's a
kind of trophy of in the in the Danish
Court and he lives long enough in order
to grow up to be it's the it's basically
the Lion King
version of The Lion King story he grows
up to be to go back and take revenge
kill off his miserable uncle and exact
revenge had become the triumphant prince
Shakespeare takes the story makes
perfect sense as to why the original
story is the why Hamlet has had to
behave like it that he's mad he takes
that story
he has instead the murders a secret and
no one knows they think it's a serpent
that's killed the old king while he's
sleeping in his garden they don't know
that the brother has poisoned him the
only one who knows is Hamlet who knows
because a ghost has told him the ghost
of his father so Hamlet is alone in the
kingdom of knowing besides the murderer
himself knowing the secret and then
Hamlet pretends he's mad it makes no
sense it made great sense in the
original version it now makes no sense
and instead of ruining the play which
you would think it might because the
whole place constructed now around
something that is crazy it actually
makes the play the greatest thing that
Shakespeare had written up to that point
the deepest the most complex the most
motivationally maddening the thing that
you can't completely I mean Hamlet is
that bone stuck in the throat of Western
civilization we keep trying to swallow
it I spit it out over and over and over
again it's in it's everywhere it's in
Freud it's in Marx
it's they the great haunting in our life
and it has to do it's not only this but
it has to do with this extraordinary
move of cutting out the motivation and
throwing it away and then he did this
again and again in the years afterwards
he discovered that he could do this so
that if you look carefully yet many of
the great plays that follow
at King Lear at a fellow you find that
he does the same thing more in 1564 died
in 1616 52 years old what year would he
have written Hamlet he brought how about
16 1 where was that in the context of
the poems that he wrote in the plays
that he had probably written he hadn't
written any of the great this is the
first of the really immediate in Romeo
and Juliet that's they were the one
major tragedy before before and then the
other outpouring of major tragedies
follows he'd written about 2/3 of what
he would eventually write
he had probably written most of the
sonnets in my view how do you teach this
what I don't want to accuse you of using
techniques but when you in a classroom
how do you approach your students and
when do you see them getting interested
lots of different ways of teaching
Shakespeare I mean one of the pleasures
of Shakespeare is is a million different
ways of getting into these plays I have
my students often look at versions of
the play videos' I have my students
sometimes act out things but mostly we
sit and look carefully try to to slow
down because I assuming that my students
are perfectly capable of though it's
hard work of reading the plays through
and getting the gist of them but it's
the ability to sit and be patient and
let it unlock itself as you can't do on
stage on stage or if you watch it in a
video it's going along at its pace and
that's fine it gives you a wonderful
effect that's meant to produce that that
effect but I do what with with
Shakespeare what people with music who
are teaching music do slow it down see
what happens see how it's put together
so that's one way of doing it another
thing I often do is to read other things
written in the same periods and that are
rather similar and see how what
Shakespeare is doing that that that the
other people aren't doing or what
changes he's make the sources for
example have students we know lots of
the sources have students look at the
sources see what happens when he takes
Plutarch and he turns it into Anthony
Becht or sometimes very very close
sometimes very daringly far away or some
I've done recently that I hadn't done
before is to have students try to think
about this as if they were going to try
to write some of these place there are a
couple of lost plays of Shakespeare so
at least one play we know for sure that
he wrote with a class and collaboration
with a playwright named Fletcher with
whom he worked on a couple of other
plays and it's lost now but we know the
source so I have the students start
playing with the source and seeing if
they can invent scenes that have a
Shakespearean feel to them try to figure
out what 10 or 20 or 50 things that
Shakespeare characteristically does how
does he do this as if as if instead of
just rolling up one's eyes and holding
up ones hands and saying this is
incomprehensibly great we could actually
figure out how this is done as if it
were done by a real human being how much
of or how many of his plays have
politics in them a lot of them have
politics in them I would say depending
on how you a broadly define the term
most of the plays have some politics in
them of some kind or other on the other
hand contemporary politics he had to be
rather careful about as did everyone in
this theatre this is a censored theater
Shakespeare was actually quite good at
staying out of jail
unlike many of his contemporaries who
censored his material well they were
there were it was censored both by
someone called a master of the Revels
who worked you would have to present the
script to the master the rebels and a
few of those scripts of the master of
the Revels his comments the censors
comments survived including one that
Shakespeare the hand in and then if you
were publishing if you're printing it it
went through a different sensor ran out
of the bishops office and he would read
the text and decide whether it could be
printed so we have two different
censoring systems working on Shakespeare
did he have secret messages and he liked
to deliver for political reasons and
what did he think of the the monarchy
it's hard to tell of course if it was
really secret I mean the and it's
probably the case that there are parts
of some secrets that we would have
difficulty unlocking I think that on the
whole but this is a subject about which
there can be many I think quite
legitimately competing views I think on
the whole he was deeply deeply skeptical
about the system of charismatic monarchy
in which he lived but I think at the
same time that he was fascinated by it
and willing to imagine it and think
through it I mean this is a writer who
wrote henry v let's say about that kind
of charismatic warrior king but it's a
strange play because on the one hand
it's a celebration of that kind of regal
heroism on the other hand Shakespeare
goes out of his way to depict this king
war during the massacre of prisoners
violating the rules of war threatening
rape behaving in a monstrous way and of
course it would be possible to say that
Shakespeare approved of that behavior
but actually I think there's very strong
internal evidence in the place that he
is not approving of this of this
behavior that he actually is interested
in in the ways in which certain kind of
charismatic Authority is often
intertwined with something that we might
call criminal behavior in that earlier
bunch of clips we showed from book notes
Maureen Dowd was there and she talked
about when she was here for book notes
about studying Shakespeare and using a
lot in her columns I want to run another
little clip about she's talking about
comparing Karl Rove to Yago and you can
explain this after a listen to but let's
listen to what she was saying then
Yago in Shakespeare Othello's
is a fellow's top military aide who
keeps whispering in his ear saying that
a fellow's wife has been unfaithful when
she hasn't because it serves his own
purposes and he makes a fellow crazy and
then a fellow ends up killing his wife
so and why karl rove well karl rove I
guess was early on because karl rove you
know it's kind of they call bush's brain
although i don't think that's her I
think Bush is bright he's just was a
more malleable than his father because
he hadn't studied up on foreign policy
as much as his dad karl rove i think you
know he he was the one they found his
computer disk or whatever and found out
that he intended to
thought you know he could win majorities
in Congress by pushing the war and so in
the beginning of the book Karl Rove is
featured as someone who wants to use war
for political purposes what do you think
of the way she used Shakespeare she's
using Yago as a figure for a kind of
cold reptilian evil can be used that way
it's a slightly strange analogy only
because you'd have to believe that karl
rove ultimately were trying to destroy
george w bush which is what a fellow
what Yago is trying to do to Othello and
I'm not sure that she's claiming that I
think she wants to was maybe we all try
to do to carve off a certain piece of
the character he is certainly the most
hateful character that Shakespeare
imagined I think and attribute that to
the manipulative dark power behind well
what do you think of using and she's not
the only one that does this using
Shakespeare to define politics I plead
guilty to the charge I haven't either
give us an exam well I confess I wrote
something about the first debate the
first presidential debate recently that
in in The Times op-ed page that simply
tried to talk about the debate between
between if if debate is the right word
for it but this debate the right word
for this current enterprise between
Anthony and Brutus over the body of
Caesar to try to decide the course of
the Republic and in which I tried to
tease out the kind of analogy rough
analogy something Maureen Dowd liked
between those two figures and the
current figures now why does one do that
as I suppose because the place are
cunning
about human behavior the plays reveal as
one of your other clips said this is
actually a very good way of thinking
about our human beings behave it's one
of our best representations that we have
available to us for the way in which
human beings behave and so it's
irresistible
another fella you talk a lot about is
Christopher Marlowe who was he
Christopher Marlowe was Shakespeare's
contemporary exact contemporary born in
1564 Shakespeare was
from a provincial town the way
Shakespeare was Canterbury and Marlowe's
case and from a middle-class family not
an aristocratic family in Marla's case
shoemaker father rather than a lover
like Shakespeare's father so they're
almost eerily like twins but Christopher
Marlowe went to Cambridge University
made it to University and made it to
London before Shakespeare made it to
London so that when checks we arrived in
London he would have encountered lots of
people in a rather wild London theatre
world but the most brilliant was
Christopher Marlowe the most adventurous
the most imaginative and the most
reckless and dangerous and I think
Marlowe made a profound impact on
Shakespeare it's sometimes said about
Shakespeare that he was so magnificently
powerful that he was completely
indifferent to his rivals but I think
this is not true I think that there's
there the fingerprints of Christopher
Marlowe all over Shakespeare's work and
very very clear clear evidence of
Shakespeare brooding about Marlowe
thinking about MSA as a rival as a model
and also as a faith a destiny that he
doesn't want for himself do I remember
correctly that Paris and Naples were the
only times bigger than London and that's
about two hundred thousand by two
hundred yeah a huge city by by European
standards London that's back in the 15
yeah there aren't there as you say there
are only three cities like this in
Europe I don't know actually whether
whether Istanbul what the size of that
was at that point but any case in these
are remarkable cities and London was
unique and certainly in the British
Isles I don't know if there's a way to
do this but Shakespeare and those times
if you moved to today how big a name
would he be can you comparing with
anybody today you suggest he was quite
an entrepreneur he owned theatres he did
make a lot of money he did he made a lot
of money and he was quite celebrated in
his times it's hard to sort of pick out
a a single figure now who
become probably because Shakespeare
dominated his industry if that's the way
to put it in a way that no one eye I
think dominates writing now let's say
I've sometimes thought because I admire
the person I and I love him as a as a
human being that Seamus Heaney the poet
has something of what I might have
encountered and Shakespeare a kind of
exuberant linguistic generosity that
that is recognized as as admirable by a
very very wide swath of people but I'm
speaking now after all of an Irish poet
not of American but if you walk around
Dublin as I once a vacation to do with
Seamus Heaney you see everyone sort of
smiles at him and knows who he is and
looks at him I mean waves to him and I
think Shakespeare had something of that
celebrity in his own time though of
course that didn't mean that anyone sat
down and wrote his biography they didn't
now today we think obvious is quite
intellectual and that was an
intellectual experience you say it was
entertainment in those days 1,500 to
2,000 people there how much did they pay
to get into one of these plays cheap
seats were if you've gone to the public
theater that is to say the outdoor
theater the globe for example you paid a
penny to get in the door and went into a
box
hence box office and the if you wanted
to get that just got you into the
theatre and got you a place where you
could stand as you know it rains from
time to time in England and the weather
is often miserable also it can even be
sunny in England unpleasantly sunny so
that if you wanted to get into a
sheltered place you had to pay another
penny to get into one of the out of the
standing area and onto a into a covered
gallery and if you wanted the cushion
that would cost you another penny so
there yeah that was in the public
theaters can you relate that form of
entertainment then there's something we
do now would it relate to Broadway or it
relate to a concert or how would you
probably I don't know comparable system
in which you would you although we have
the we have the we've changed the rules
in a way now our rule is the more you
pay the closer you get to the stage in
those days than where you pay
further back in effect you were under
there one of the canopies but I think
that the experience would probably be
closer to a a constant rock concert or
maybe a football game then it would have
been - decorous entertainments that we
think of us as theatre after all week
there's lots of evidence that that
prostitutes of working the theaters and
people were selling oranges and other
things to munch on drinks at the theater
I mean it was a it was a much rougher by
our standards much rougher world what
was the first thing he ever wrote no one
knows for sure the dates of this of
these things aren't so clear if you
really want to know the first thing that
I think we have a trace of that he wrote
I think there's a little jingle that he
wrote to sell gloves in his father's
workshop that is Shakespeare's a jingle
that someone in Alexander Aspen all
bought some gloves I think at the
Shakespeare family a glove shop and
there's a poem that survives in a
commonplace book as it's called people
kept these records it says the will the
gift is small the will is all Alexander
Aspen all he gave it to his woman he was
courting and the person who wrote that
in the commonplace book in the 17th
century said Posey on a pair of gloves
written by mr. Shakespeare so I think
Shakespeare was probably a teenager and
wrote that totally undistinguished
little poem jingle to go with the gloves
but the first serious there's there's
lots of leeway to argue about this but
probably to gentlemen of verona what
year again these things are very very
difficult to say maybe the late 1580s
could have been another play too could
have been the Henry that whenever Henry
the sixth place so he would have been in
his late thirties oh no in in the I know
20s late galleries yeah
the first you say the first seventeen
sonnets in yeah you say he wrote a one
hundred and seven hundred and fifty four
sides yes first seventeen were written
for the Earl of Southampton well that's
what I say but but we don't they we
don't know for sure and we don't
for sure because they're rather can
either these poems when you're not
identifying exactly whom they're being
written for or identifying exactly what
the social situation is in which they're
being written there that's the game
that's on it's played in this period
sonnets are our curtain rooms and there
are more and more diaphanous curtains
around them and you look through the
curtain you think you see someone doing
something somewhere back in there but
you can't be sure who it is at what
they're doing at Shakespeare was a
genius at constructing those little
boxes within boxes did he have a
personal relationship with Errol
something he did that we do know because
almost the only documents of the kind
that we have are the two dedicatory
epistles that he wrote for the two
narrative poems the long marvelous
mythological poem Venus and Adonis and
the classical poem the rape of Lucretia
that he wrote for both of which are
dedicated in extravagant terms
particularly the rate of increase in
very very loving terms to the erosive
have been unusually intimate language
for a poet of no particular social
standing to write to an earl who is of
absolutely the highest point of the
social hierarchy you talk about
Christopher Marlowe and William
Shakespeare writing a play about Jews
and then you also tie that into the fact
that this Spanish Jews out of the the
country and that there were no Jews in
in Great Britain back in his time
explain all that and what was being the
English had had performed their act of
ethnic cleansing before any other
country in Europe 1290 I think it was
that they expelled the Jews of England
for reasons that are not clear my
mastery quantico we construct the usual
anti-semitic story the so that when
Shakespeare was writing there were no
Jews legally no Jewish community in
England there might have been a few
people who belong to Morano communities
secret Jews but we don't really have
very clear record of this there was some
rumors of this kind there were some
people who were
from conversa families that is to say
they were families of that that had been
Jewish a generation or more more before
but it converted to Catholicism under
pressure of the persecutions for first
in Spain and then in Portugal and one of
those people from a family that had been
Jewish a generation or more before was
was the Queen's physician named Lopez
were Lopez and he fell into trouble in
the 1590s accused of having accepted a
very large bribe from the king of Spain
to do some skullduggery and it was
charged the skullduggery was poisoning
the Queen whether it's true or not your
guess is as good as mine there are some
people think there is some evidence for
it some people think there wasn't that
he was on the take is very very likely
but everyone who was in the court who
had access to the Queen was almost
certainly on the take in this period
that's the way the system worked the
clothes he were to the person in power
the more money you could make I know
this never happens any longer but in
those days it it happened two plays so
what happened was that Christopher
Marlowe had written a very brilliant
play called the Jew of Malta brilliant
but wild and reckless that was
anti-semitic also anti-christian manty
Muslim you name it it was ante in a kind
of very very reckless play it was
successful and it was revived on
numerous occasions in one time it was
almost certainly revived was at the time
that the charges came against this man
Lopez because the prosecutor at the
trial at recent trial for Lopez said not
only you are agent of the Jesuits the
wicked Catholics the king of Spain but
you are a Jew and you're you are worse
than Judas and so forth and so on Lopez
said he was a Christian good Christian
and when Lopez was taken out to be
executed queen protected him for a while
and finally withdrew protection Lopez
was taken out to be executed and the
executions were unspeakably horrible in
this period but were also major public
events
and he said from the scaffold in his
speech when he was bidding farewell to
the world he said that the charges
against him were not true and that he
loved the Queen as much as he loved
Jesus Christ and the crowd that was at
the foot of the scaffold burst into
laughter now why did they burst into
laughter they burst into laughter
because they thought that he was lying
but specifically they thought he was
making a joke and then we where they had
learned that joke was from Christopher
Marlowe
because Marlowe's Jewish hero had the
hero bare of us who poisons people is a
doctor who poisons people of poisons
Wells does every unspeakable thing he's
always making jokes of this kind I love
you with a burning zeal enough to burn
your house down he says in a aside or
someone says how much it's gonna cost
you oh just your life he says that means
a little planning to kill someone and so
forth it's that kind of Joker so I love
you as much as I love Jesus Christ is a
Marlo vien joke and I think Shakespeare
was in the crowd watching this execution
and I think he heard that laughter and I
think he had two different kinds of
responses to the laughter that abraded
together in the play that he wrote that
was in effect a response to the Jew of
Malta and the play he wrote was the
Merchant of Venice and the two responses
are on the one hand this is a man who
makes his profession making people laugh
he's interested in crowd laughter and he
is excited by the fact that he's heard
this mass response and there's lots of
laughter in the Merchant of Venice the
Merchant of Venice is obsessed with
laughed at people are always talking
about laughing when will we laugh again
how can I make you laugh and so forth
and so on at the same time I think he
was made tremendously uncomfortable by
the laughter at that execution and I
think that that discomfort is eloquently
registered in the Merchant of Venice
where every time you want to laugh at
[ __ ] the laughter turns to a kind of
gagging you're in your throat and this
is a very very complex comedy as anyone
who's ever seen it
form that nose because we're near the
end he died in 1616 of what we don't
know we have a record that says he drank
a lot his daughter was getting married
you listen maybe did drink a lot more
than you should have but it's not likely
that a father drinks too much in his
daughter's wedding is gonna die of it so
we don't know if I heard right this
morning you've been nominated for the
National Book Award today I have the day
we're taping this yes was that a
surprise to a complete surprise have you
ever had this before are you kidding
no I'm delighted what does it mean the
dog surprise I I wanted very much in
this book to figure out a way of of
telling an audience other than the the
audience that I usually write for which
I'm happy about the audience of people
who read academic books of telling them
about this astonishing life but telling
them about what in the 40 years of
thinking about Shakespeare I've learned
about this human being of of crossing a
line from the world little swimming pool
in which I'm happily paddling around
most of my life to a much larger pool or
at least maybe it may be something even
bigger than a pool and that that's what
this means to me that this book has has
reached the audience that I had dreamt
that it might reach will in the world
how Shakespeare became Shakespeare by
our guest Stephen Greenblatt the cover
of the book looks like this thank you
very much for joining us thank you very
much Brian